okay let's go back to the phone lines at
6 1 7 8 3 0
4750 we will go to our caller from the
three three six area code who's calling
today from three three six uh hi David
my name is Ricardo three three six I'm
from winston-salem but I'm University
student in Charlotte North Carolina
alright very good Ricardo what's on your
mind today so I know you've been talking
a lot about Venezuela
recently and I just want to touch back
on the topic so a lot of people on the
Left even on her left wing YouTube
channels like secular talk humorous
report rational national they are like
are you for that the u.s. is backing it
too because of course they talk about
like Ellie Abrams and his horrible past
and like many other things are the the
history the United States and also John
Bolton's push for regime change in Iran
well what he wishes to have but I just
want to ask you like how would you rebut
the the left wings concern on a coup or
they actually believe there will be a
cue that's what they believe in without
the necessary evidence and how would you
also rebut Russian media because I've
been watching reports from our teen
Sputnik and I don't really trust them I
just want to get a Russian perspective
but they're very Pro versus a little
coup without necessary evidence okay so
I wouldn't even worry about rebooting
Russian state media I mean right there
there's a sort of there's a sort of
triumvirate or a Hydra that includes
Russian interests in Syria Russian
interests in Venezuela and Russian
interests in meddling with American
elections and we know what they're doing
we know what their positions are I mean
I would I'm no more interested in
rebutting RT on the issue of Venezuela
that I am on rebutting Venezuelan state
media wow I'm shocked the Venezuelan
state media says Maduro is great and
everything is you know waterfalls and
rainbows I'm not super interested in
that I think the first thing you
mentioned is more in
now I don't know what any of those shows
you mentioned have said because I don't
really watch anything I just mostly read
so I think that anyone who is making the
case that Elliott Abrams involvement in
Latin America is bad for Latin America
is right I agree with that anyone who is
making the case that the United States
should not be involved in deciding who
is ultimately the president of Venezuela
is right I agree with that anyone who is
making the case that the United States
involvement in Latin America has been a
disaster for those countries and serves
as evidence for opposing such
involvement in Venezuela I'm right there
with them and and then I would say
Maduro needs to go Maduro is an
authoritarian the economy has been in
freefall since before American sanctions
were instituted since before the decline
of oil prices which are the two sort of
talking points that are most common from
some people on the Left if it weren't
for that decline in oil prices if it
weren't for American sanctions the
decline in Venezuela long predates that
Maduro has to go there are too many
similarities to Castro in Cuba who I
also believed was an authoritarian and
undeniably is and that that's sort of
where I am on it
see I agree with you a lot but there's
still a lot of people and luckily a
chance though I know you don't have the
time to see left-wing channels but what
they're arguing is that since of course
like Elliott Abrams in the guise of aid
he sent actually weapons to help like
Contras in Nicaragua they're arguing
without necessary evidence that the US
aid that the United is trying to
transfer to Minnesota actually has
weapons or something to lead a coup but
again there's no evidence to that but of
course many left-wing channels argue
that without the evidence and they also
are like you've already talked about big
criticizing burning and I don't think
they're really changing the position so
I don't know what because a lot of
people are really on to this and I don't
know how they change your opinion
because they don't feel like they don't
really care about the evidence yeah they
don't care about the that's that's
actually the problem that there's a lot
of people who'd it's
unfortunately there's this sort of
litmus test politics that is
unfortunately happening you know I mean
it's been happening on the right for a
long time but it's also happening on the
left where you're basically ostracized
if you don't sort of toe the line when
it comes to certain issues and Venezuela
has become one of those where there's
very little room for sort of dissenting
voices they're immediately called
neoliberal shills or whatever and you
know we sort of need a multi-layered
thought when it comes to this and I
don't think I don't know that you're
really going to change anyone's mind I
don't know that I would try to oh thank
you so much alright really appreciate
the call thank you